And the worst thing is the biggest mistake I've ever made in
my life was that I was too loyal. Like you know,
you know if you watch my content for any amount of time ever.
I wake up every morning in the middle of the night just
He wakes up every morning in the middle of the night. That's
how that's how much of a victim he is. Okay. And he wakes up
every morning in the middle of the >> I wake up every morning
in the middle of the night just wondering,
did they lie again?
>> We're doing We're doing a little drama, some techone
stuff. Let's check it out. >> What's up, guys? This is
now my third time trying to record this video. And I think that
goes to show just how up I am, cuz I'm usually like a one take
guy. It's It's been a couple days. I've been gone for about 5
days. Maybe you haven't even noticed. You probably haven't even
>> I'm sure. I hope your viewers noticed. >> If you
see this video, it means I'm already gone. Title of the video.
Tech. I thought you were dead.
This video title scared the [__] out of
Uh, you can never stop click baiting, man. That's the name of
the game. Maybe some of you guys have noticed the uh stopping
of YouTube uploads. Maybe some of you guys have noticed the stopping
of YouTube streams and Twitch streams and even Twitter posts.
But I've now been
content creation free for a while now. And uh just to give the
TLDDR on this gonna be a pretty rambly video. So I mean maybe
some of you guys will like it, maybe some of you guys won't.
But
uh content creation he's like shaking. I'm content creation free,
guys. Content creation free.
>> I'm I'm going to be gone for a while, guys. And uh I
I want to let you know >> Oh, no.
If any of you guys think it's because of me streaming
or me being stressed because the YouTube's, you know, upload
schedule, it's not. I love content creation. I do. It's just
the culture that I have a problem with. But if if if you're just
here to know this, no, I'm not coming back yet. No, I'm not going
to be back for a while. Um, and yes, I do miss you because I
love you. No, I miss making content for you guys. I really do.
And uh I will say expect a couple YouTube uploads, maybe like
one a week. I'll just >> Okay,
let's be real. One YouTube upload a week is not quitting content
creation by any stretch of the imagination. If he does one YouTube
video a week, that's not even close to quitting content creation.
What are we doing? >> Just be talking to you guys about
whatever comes into my mind. Maybe more. But uh I I I needed
to get away for a while. I really did. In case you're wondering
why there are evil people on this earth that are
currently making my life miserable even
Oh, good. I thought this was maybe going to be a video about,
you know, him growing as a person, but actually,
actually, dude, my ex-girlfriend who accused me of sexual assault,
she's destroying my [__]
life.
Oh, I thought I thought he grew for a second and you know, same
old tech tone. Same old techone is here with us right now. >> Even
more than you guys know, it is deeply personal that I'm having
to deal with right now. And a lot of it and and I I'm I'm not
going to go into this too much, but there's a lot of very dangerous
things happening in my life right now that I'm just trying to
take care of and take care of the people around me, the people
who I love. And uh I'll probably talk about that later. But uh
when I do come back, I I'll post about it on Twitter. I'll post
about it on YouTube. And just thank you guys for staying subscribed
and thank you guys for liking my videos. And uh I I look forward
to coming back to content creation for you guys, but once again,
it's just not going to be for a while. >> As dirt on Miskf,
and he's alluded to it, alluded not eluded to it being part of
what he's going to release when he comes back. Oh. Um well, he
dropped some info on Miskf. He basically said that all of OTK
had to confront Msk on his rampant botting. What is this music?
This is the uh this is the all for one theme from My Hero Academia.
Perfect when you got edgy boys being edgy. Okay, great song.
So, yeah, he already alluded to like all of OTK having to warn
Miskf, right? Or sorry, warn Misk that needs to stop. Techone
hates Miskf and a stories.
Damn.
Yeah. So, I don't know. Maybe he's got more stuff for Miskf when
he comes back, but he he hates Msk. >> So, now with all
that out of the way, hopefully I can feel better. just kind of
just getting some things off my chest for for why I'm kind of
going and you know kind of extrapolate on the previous things
that I've been saying. I'm a guy where I've been doing this for
nearly 7 years. 7 years coming up in December and uh I always
think that I'm okay. I do. I'm not. And I know I'm not okay.
I wasn't sleeping well. Uh I wasn't happy. I was crashing out
over things that didn't even bother me. I was saying things I
didn't mean. Like for example, I I told another viewer to kill
yourselves and I know that's nobody >> that is a sign of
mental sanity, okay? Mental wellness, Teone, he's this is his
problem. Nobody can tell him that. Techone, that means you're
very like doing well. You're actually very healthy right now.
It's against the toos. He shouldn't do it. But like that is that
feeling. If you're just like, "My chat's awesome. I want them
all the I wish them all the best." Yeah, that's uh that's not
a good sign, buddy. That's not a good sign at all. >> Damn,
that [__] You know, I shouldn't be saying that [__]
It's going to be a hard one to stop, but like I don't like when
I let things come out of my mouth that I don't feel like I could
have stopped. Yeah, I I feel bad for that. I really >> Oh,
is that what he said? That's shockingly similar to what Darius
said in the video that got me terminated from >> Crazy.
The problem in my life is is that I'm a guy
who lost a lot of [__] because
one evil person
decided to lie
and the
>> Dude, I'm a guy who lost a lot of cuz one evil
person decided to lie.
That evil person who lied, by the way, did so apparently. I think
I think he had like 700,000 subs, 600,000 subs. He's actually
gotten like 500,000 subs since that whole thing happened. He's
like doubled his channel size easily. He's like massively massively
scaling up and blowing up, right? It's so insane. This is uh
the all for one theme. All for one My Hero Academia. But yeah,
so he's going back into his uh his ex again. One person lied.
Dude, his like psychopathic
like hatred for this person is pretty crazy. like the what what
do I what do I think on this? It's like the the
worst sorry the best case scenario for him in that case is like
there was some misunderstood consent some misunder it was like
dubious consent and actually she had consent and
and that was uh
and like it was just a misunderstanding and and
realistically if he just made a statement like yeah it's I like
I've never done anything like that but I understand like it's
crazy she thinks that we'll let the cops solve it and then you
just move on right just move on It's so easy.
>> But now
I'm being told even >> Okay, hold on. This is apparently
one of the things he got banned for. Wasn't just telling somebody
to kill >> Got banned on Twitch today after threatening
the viewer and dropping. >> Is that a confession? No. Shut
the [__] up, you weird. How about I kill you in real
life? Good lord. Being weird as >> Shut up, you weird fsler.
Why don't I you in real life? >> But it it it is insane
how like we are >> Hold on. Did I get that right? >> Confession.
No. Shut the [__] up, you weird. How about I you
>> Yeah, it was that that is what it was. >> Good
lord being weird as but it it it is insane how like we are no
longer call like like this is why we need to bring the word fat
back, right? The reason >> No, he didn't. He did not say
weird. He did not say weird karaoko. He did not say weird. This
is why we need to bring the word back. Yeah. No, he did not say
weird. Reason why that is is because when the internet says we
can't say [__] we can't say it, we can't say, you
know, any of these words right now. Creators have gone and said,
"Oh, oh, oh [__] Do I see new content from the the
queen
Britney Simon?
What is this? Don't let these liberal men gaslight you. 3hour
VOD from Britney Simon. 3-hour video 6 hours ago. I I wonder
what that could possibly be about. I have no idea actually. >> I
kind of thought it would be about hutch or something, but I have
no idea what it would be about to tell you the >> Or this
other word. So now we're going to call you aile. Now we're going
to call you a
uh now we're going to call you an abuser. Now we're going to
call you a assaulter because you took away the fun he he hhaha
words from the internet that did not get.
Dude,
do you think do you really think that like if if your ex could
have only called you an abs slur on the internet, she would never
have gone to the cops with this allegation? Is that what he's
suggesting in this clip? If only if only, guys. And and when
my when my ex went to the cops, people would never have followed
that action up by calling me the things that I'm accused of by
her, right? Never. Ever. Ever.
They would have totally just called me an epsler instead. No.
Obviously, you wouldn't even This guy wouldn't crash out if he
got called the epsler, right?
This guy wouldn't crash out at all. He would instead of crashing
out, he would just like laugh and talk [__] back.
But when when people call him a he loses his mind even if they're
accurate, even they say accuse or something, he loses his mind.
Yeah, I I'm sorry. You show your ass like that, people are going
to use it against you. That's just facts. More so
that I can't talk about anything and I need to watch. >> Wait,
what are you reporting him for? I'm reporting him for being a
it of it.
See, I'm I'm mimicking the the censor sound. An f slur. That's
what I'm reporting him for. That's her filling out her police
report. Okay. >> Touch everything. >> It will just
be pay. >> Hold on. Reuben. Ruben. >> Reuben. Ruben
donated $3. You better check on yourself before you checked on
yourself. D. Okay, thank you, Ruben. >> and I just can't
operate underneath those. I I can't operate like that. I can't.
I'm a guy who tells you guys everything.
I'm the guy who likes >> tells it like it is >> the
distance that a lot of these people in this space
lie to you. I like letting you guys know on what's actually going
on. And that's why a lot of people can't stand my ads. Dude,
it's
How is every
like narcissist
ever like this? Like there are so many people if somebody ever
tells you that, right? Oh, uh, listen, I'm a truth teller and
that's why people don't like me. It's just insane. It's an insane
commentary like every time. I've known I don't actually know
I'm sure there are a lot of people on the internet who do this.
I can think of like um friends from like uh like five 10 years
ago who who would say this and I'm just like you hear them say
it's like no that's not at all why people don't like you. Come
on man come on dude really you think people don't like you cuz
you tell the truth. Was it really was it really your commitment
to telling the truth that made you call that woman fat as we
were coming up the stairs? Was that your commitment to the truth?
Are you just kind of
which which is it? Let's be real, man.
Uh, and you know, there's a lot of other reasons, too. I mean,
I'm loud, bald, weird looking. I don't want to say ugly.
Well, I'm working on it. Okay. I'm down 100 lbs, right? I'm really
trying my best here, but man, like I haven't showered in like
2 3 days or some [__]
>> Yeah, exactly. Exa. Everybody knows exactly who that
person is, right? Everybody knows who that person. Everybody's
met that person. And it's just like, dude, who are you fooling?
Who are you trying to fool right now? Meanwhile, Crusty, thank
you for the nine months. Nine months. I was going to say 19.
Nine months. Thank you very much. I'm >> full like grease
goblin right now, man. It's gross. Oh, I got a new tattoo, by
the way. It's uh mango with the frost in his mouth on the tombstone
like from Dark Souls 1 with Galatians 4:16. That's my favorite
Bible verse on there. Uh there's a reference to Sith from Dark
Souls 1. And I also got a fire for anybody who didn't get it.
And also cuz it looks getting more. >> Wow, that's so cool.
>> I do. probably getting a collar bone tattoo and a getting
all this arm sleeved up. Getting the American flag pretty soon
with uh a little bit more than the American flag, but I'm very
excited about that. But yeah. >> Um yeah, exactly. Evil
Johnny Bravo. The people who do the people who do tell the truth
don't like invoke it. They might invoke it if you ask like why
people don't like them. If you're like explicitly saying it,
if you're like, right, if you if you engage or if you interrogate
like their their thought process, right, they might eventually
say it, but people know to like if that's like just something
you say sort of unprovoked,
do you always It's like just 100% of the time you're an >> Yeah.
The the problem with my life currently is that >> is that
you don't take responsibility for any of the things happening
to you. You you cast that responsibility on to other people.
You refuse to introspect or look at the things you could do better
um in terms of your interpersonal relationships. That's what
it is. Techone. Now, please, for the love of God, identify that.
Okay? Identify that.
Remember, remember the aerodyite convo where he's basically like,
"No, no, no. I've never been wrong about another person ever.
I've just never been wrong." And then the one time he was wrong,
he was like, "Oh, wait, no, I have been wrong. One time I trusted
this guy too much and then he stabbed me in the back and I kept
trusting him. It's like, bruh,
>> I don't get any time to feel okay. I don't get any time
to
relax and say, I'm good. I can chill for the day. And what do
I mean by that? My problem is so much of my life has been taken
away from me by a lie.
>> Dude,
the the lie I I believe it's like just patently obvious, okay,
that the lie is that he assaulted his ex, right? That's the lie
here. And he's like, "So much of my life has been taken away."
What? What's been taken away, dude? Like two weeks ago. No, sorry.
Like 6 to 8 weeks ago. You're collabing with like Donut Operator
and a whole bunch of other people cuz you went and helped uh
the disaster relief in Texas. Like you've had massive massive
collabs.
Oh, who have you lost out on? I think it's I think it's Mythic
Talent by the way. I think he ended up something happened with
Mythic Talent where they just booted both him and Pinky Chu,
right? I don't know exactly what that was, but he's like he's
basically like victimizing himself saying, "Guys, feel bad for
me." But he's not even going to talk about what actually happened
>> that I don't get to go to sleep and think, "Oh, well,
I didn't do anything bad today, so I'm all good." You know, back
in the day, it was like, "Oh man, I up." I know they're going
to clip that and that's going to be on this Reddit, that's going
to be on that Twitter, that's going to be on that uh forum. They're
going to rip into me. And that's comforting cuz then knowing
if I don't do anything up then I'm fine. The problem is is that
because I'm now in a
where there's this massive lie told about me. I never get to
rest
ever. I wake up every morning in the middle of the night just
wondering. >> So Cherry posted this clip to Twitter. I
don't know if you guys saw it. Okay. She pointed this out um
to me at least that Tekon claims he wakes up every morning in
the middle of the night. That's how that's how much of a victim
he is. Okay. He wakes up every morning in the middle of the night.
Listen to that again. >> Where there's this massive lie
told about me. I >> They're They're lying about me. They're
lying about me. >> Never get to rest
ever. I wake up every morning in the middle of the night just
did they lie again?
>> I'm just picturing him waking up next to his girlfriend.
Like it middle of the night. Okay. Not every morning, the middle
of the night, but in the morning, let's say, or in the middle
of the night, either one. He's like tossing and turning and he
goes and she's like, "Oh my god, Tone, what's wrong?" He's like,
"Did they lie again? Did they lie again? I can't sleep. Did they
lie again?"
No. Middle of the night, just wondering,
did they lie again?
Did someone else lie?
What false narrative is the public going to believe about me?
The secret to time travel being lied
>> No, it's annoying issue. Like once again, I love YouTube.
I love Twitch, but the culture of the internet is terrible where
good people have to worry about being considered a horrific person
due to things they've never even done. >> Uh, that's literally
everywhere, by the way. Also, that's all celebrities.
That's not about the internet. That's all celebrities ever. There
are plenty of celebrities who have some story where they get
accused of something.
Like uh okay, OJ's probably not the best example, but like OJ
got really famous for a case where he was exonerated, right?
Kind of exoner not exonerated, found innocent. Okay, but like
he you do have to deal with that. If you're famous, you get accused
of some really bad [__] You are going to have to
deal with that reputation following you. OJ didn't do it. I think
the prevailing theory is it's probably his kid who did it, right?
But like he like he had he probably helped his kid cover it up
or something. I think that's like the prevailing theory,
but it it's just always been the case that you if you get like
some story like that attached to you, you do have to deal with
it. But that's a part of being a celebrity. You don't you want
to know how you get away with um or you know you want to know
how you get away from that, you just quit. You don't be a celebrity
anymore. And then that doesn't follow you. You don't have to
answer to it. You don't have to deal with it at all. That is
a part of being a celebrity is is there could be things that
you might be innocent of that will be attached to you and you
have to deal with the fact that some people will bring it up.
>> Your pay and other people won't care. >> Reuben
donated $3. Lies come out his mouth so much that his hairline
wants nothing to do with it. >> Oh w Reuben Reuben.
That's fantastic. Okay. Yes. His hair flees the lies
spilling from his mouth.
Yes.
Many such cases. Now, I will say that chapter is coming to a
close soon. And I promise you guys when I get to close this chapter
this year, by the way,
I'm going to make some banging epic content. I'm not going to
lie, the content is going to be fire. React slop for the piggies.
Let's go.
Hey, that person's video, that's mine now. Yes, sir. React slop.
No, >> I I don't know why that's the one like authentic
part of the video where I just I'm like that's funny. Like I
I kind of get how he's like I get how he's a streamer, right?
React slap for the piggies. Let's go. That video is mine now.
And then he he stops and goes, "But no, seriously, I'm going
to plan some events and stuff." I don't know why you wouldn't
just plan your events now. Why take a bunch of time off? Just
like instead of taking time off, plan your events. Do your events.
Just do your events only, right? If you got like plans for for
like creative content, why not start putting that out there?
This is the worst thing you can do if you have like some plan.
I do this all the time. I'm a I'm a prolific procrastinator.
Okay? If you have plans, figure out how to get them accomplished
as quickly as possible. Don't don't like be like, "Oh, this is
going to be really cool when I do this down the road." Okay?
Don't do that. That's horrible. >> I actually got some
cool events planned. I got I got so many future plans cuz like
I know I'm going to close this chapter of my life and move forward.
I'm looking forward to that [__] so much. But it's
been aing pain, bro. It's been a pain. There's so many bad people
out there. It's actually wild. And uh that's something that I
guess I can just talk about,
guys. I'm soing bitter. I'm just old. Old old and bitter. Thought
about making a podcast called the Old and Bitter Podcast. Bro,
I hate these [__] people in this space. I do. I do.
I'm I'm so disgusted with these people that I don't even want
to put myself in a situation where I might even see them. Guys,
I'm sorry.
Fraudulent [__] run rampant on this platform. They
do. And in thising town, it's so bad. It's so bad. >> This
would be the Mizzy reference. I I have no doubt. Okay, this is
the Misk reference we're all waiting for. You know, fraudulent
[__] run rampant on this platform and in this
>> like three doors down from my house.
>> And in thising town, it's so bad. It's so bad. Let's
watch this video on like what happened to Austin, Texas. And
all
libs from California
came over to Austin and they just ruined this town, bro. I mean,
as a guy who lived in Austin, like back since like 2012, 2011,
maybe 2013,
>> Bro, we've seen what you looked like in 2011, 2012,
or whatever. The He's also Do you need a three-year window for
when you arrived in Austin?
It's around the time you bought your house, by the way, just
so you know. In any case, Oh, wait. Maybe it's not. Maybe he
bought the house way later. He might have bought the house way
later, actually.
In any case, okay, we saw what you look like. We know you didn't
go outside. Trust me. one one uh
one nighttime creature to another. Okay, Techone,
we know you didn't go outside. I know what people look like who
don't go outside and I can see you. Okay, >> that was yours.
It's so different now. It is. It's so different.
>> Oh, he lived in Texas before he went to Canada. I got
it >> like that
because loyalty doesn't exist in this space. Oh, you're a slight
inconvenience to my content or my brand. Drop you like a [__]
dime immediately. It is pathetic.
These people are soing weak.
>> I legitimately think that he could have handled the
pink thing way differently and not really been in trouble for
it, right?
Like I understand that it's frustrating and his frustrations
from it have led to him like reacting badly and things getting
like a little worse. Okay, I understand how those those things
progressed or whatever. All right, hold on. I get the volume
right on this. There we go. Uh I understand how that progressed
and that's like frustrating. you you feel like it's blown up
a bunch of but if you just been less skitso about it if you hadn't
like constantly been attacking her I feel like cuz she's not
going to stop because you attack her she's just going to be miserable
you're going to look like you're both she's going to be miserable
you're going to be an
not she's not going to take back the police report because you
harass her
what are you doing buddy
yeah so I don't know he talks about how it's like ruined his
life I I feel like your response is what's ruining at least those
connections
right like you give people no room to see you as an actual victim
if you like or or like give you any charity if you just keep
attacking this person over and over again. It's like, bro, if
I was a streamer right now, you and I'm going to make >> Brother,
you you literally you
maybe this is the schizophrenia. I don't know. Where does he
think he is? Techone, you are a streamer right now. Techone.
Techone.
you're literally a streamer right now.
weak. It's like, bro, if I was a streamer right now, you and
I'm going to make a whole video on this, by the >> dude.
This is like the This is the guy who um who starts a new diet
or something and he's like, "If I was if I was, you know, eating
unhealthy right now,
brother, you've been not streaming for like 4 days." 5 days.
You've been content creation free for 5 days. Let's chill on
saying uh you're not a streamer >> I'm going to make a
whole video on the journey of being a viewer to a content
Man, if I was a CC right now, I wouldn't want to talk to anybody.
Straight up, I would not talk to
These people are so fake, it's
And that's that's my problem is that
I've become so disgusted
with other content creators. I've I've become so disgusted with
the culture on
>> with this whole town
that I don't even want to partake in this [__] when
I get back. And I will I will be back. Not for a while.
And I appreciate you guys sticking around with me. The group
I'm going to be chilling with, the content that I >> I'm
just telling you guys, okay? When he says, "I'm not going to
be around for a while." What he actually means is, "Guys, I'm
taking a vacation and I'll I'll just be like posting my videos,
right? I'm taking a content vacation. I'm like kind of stressed.
I'm I've got all the money in the world. I don't need to work.
So, I'm going to take a
right?" And he's still going to be posting content. He's still
going to be posting on Twitter. He's like, "I'm going to take
It's like going to your job and being like, "Guys,
I'm going to h what's a good example?" I don't know if there
is a good example, but he's like he's just cutting his hours
down, right? He's still doing all the exact same things. He's
going to post YouTube content. he's going to be involved on Twitter.
He's just like taking he's taking some time off. That's it. But
like to pretend that it's because you're being harassed or anything
like that,
I I I just think it's so disingenuous.
Just say you want to take some time and and chill. >> And
I appreciate you guys sticking >> Say that you want to
play your video games that you used to love that you used to.
Right. That's to be honest that sometimes I feel like um I feel
like that's something I could almost take a vacation for is just
want to play like some civ for like 3 days. I I could take a
vacation for that, right? I could I could take some time off.
There's something different about playing games by yourself.
But just I don't know why
you can't say that because he loves to stream. I'm sure he loves
to stream.
Sometimes it sucks to have a crowd of people watching you do
something. Sometimes you just want to up and not have a whole
crowd make fun of you for it. Okay. Sometimes.
You know how you know how terrifying it is to open lockpicks
or sorry to to try to lockpick in Oblivion? You know how terrifying
that [__] is in front of a crowd of people? All right.
Break one lockpick, break two lockpicks, break a 100 lockpicks
and people mock you forever. Okay. Is crazy >> around with
me. The group I'm going to be chilling with, the content that
I make, the way that I carry myself is going to be way different.
I am a bitter, bitter, bitter man. And you wanted why I know
you want to know why I'm so bitter
because the more you get informed in this world, the more you
realize how disgusting this world is. Dude, this this is like
I think is it is it just that this guy didn't have a social life
when he was 20,
right? Like everybody has heard everybody's been sitting around
a table late at night studying in university, college, whatever,
and heard this guy talk and he's like doing his whole thing.
The more you get informed, the more the more blackpilled, the
more bitter I am about the world. Bro, that's like this is like
what comic book nerds think adults sound like. I don't I don't
get it. Like when you're 30, you should understand how like cringe
this sounds. As you get more informed, I just been getting bitter.
I'm a bitter, bitter man. As you get more informed about this
world, you realize what do you realize? >> You want to
Why? No. You want to know why I'm so bitter?
Because the more you get informed in this world, the more you
realize how disgusting this world is. >> The more you get
informed about this world, the more you realize
it's a deeply disgusting place. The human race
is a virus. >> I I want everyone to know I'm not taking
this break so I can be happy again. Absolutely not. I mean, I'm
doing this because I want to enjoy my life. I'm >> Yeah.
Moody Morgan, I don't know. I don't know where you live or what
you're doing, but you don't realize that when you hit your 30s.
You realize that at like 23, 24. You realize it maybe even a
little earlier, depending on how much you're interested in like
politics and stuff. This is not a 30-year-old realization.
You don't realize this after 6 years of paying taxes and bills
and all of this. You realize this like as that hits you or earlier
if you like actually look into current events. If you actually
try to get informed on >> very happy when I hang out with
my dog, my cats, my beautiful ass girlfriend, which one day I
plan on making my wife. Absolutely.
But man,
I see all these people now who are living in this augmented version
of reality and I feel pity for them. >> Me after my 5day
digital detox. Okay. Me after being off Twitter for 5 days. But
POV, you just left Twitter for 5 days.
But man,
I see all these people now who are living in this augmented version
of reality and I feel pity for them.
This this guy needs to All right. Can we pull up Can we get a
little techone versus techone? Cuz I think he had some excellent
advice earlier today for himself. Okay. >> And racism.
>> Excellent advice. >> You weird. How about I get
you in real life? Good lord being weird as but it it it is insane
how like we are no longer call like like this is why we need
to bring the word fat idiot. I have no idea what that is. Uh
wait is that a confession? No. Shut the [__] up you
weird. How about I kill you in real life? Good lord being weird
as >> I feel sorrow for them because I know everything
that they're living in can
>> Dude, there's no way this guy.
It's so
[__] fake.
It's insane. >> Been off Twitter and content creation for
five
days.
Five days.
>> Feel sorrow in this beautiful ass girlfriend which one
day I make >> I I just have to run the whole thing front
to back one more time. >> I see all these people now who
are living in this augmented version of reality and I feel pity
for them. I feel sorrow for them because I know everything that
they're living in
can disappear like that. It's so
[__] fake.
It's insane. Wow.
Wow. I'm so glad we have accused Teone to bring us these incredible
insights. He's willing He's willing after being accused. Okay.
Kind of pretty pretty credibly of sex assault. All right.
He's willing to take 5 days off of Twitter and just bring us
these insights from outside the Matrix. Okay, this guy's unplugged
and he's trying to wake you up. Wake up. He's trying to red pill
the audience. Okay, wake up. You're living in a dream world,
guys. The sad realization is there's so little good people on
this earth. It's
surprising. There's a lot of okay people, okay people that will
make you think that they're great people.
But I've said this once and I'll say this before. Your friends
in elementary school are gone in middle school. Your friends
in middle school are gone in high school. Your friends in high
school are gone in college. Your friends in college are gone
once you get a job. Your friends in your job are gone once you
leave that job. Yeah. Wait, this is actually bordering on insight.
Yes, it is incredibly difficult to maintain friendships that
form from proximity. If you have friendships that are based on
proximity, it is very difficult to maintain those unless you
do actual like meticulous work to maintain them. And that's really
difficult because the further somebody is away from you, the
less you see them, the easier it is to just like kind of let
things slide,
right? Yeah. Absolutely.
There are some people who you share experiences with who you'll
always be friends with. But even with those people, once you
stop sharing proximity, I think it starts to become something
more like, yeah, like if I see you, like we could hang out or
you know, if you're in town, we'll hang out. But like you don't
keep up to them on a up with them on a day-to-day basis. There's
very very few people who have any friends like that. And it requires
both friends being like hyperinvested in the other person and
wanting to make that happen. With Techone, I I just don't think
he's like that with people. I've never I've never seen any indication,
right? And maybe not even Techone. Almost any streamer, I can't
imagine being like that. I just I can't see it. Like, yeah, I
I could see tech I can see streamers who are very social, who
have really good friends, but I think non-proximal friends. I
guess most streamers don't hang on to those >> True true
friends are so rare. Also,
proximity based friends are true friends. They can be true friends.
I have a lot of friends who I've fallen out of touch with from
college that if I messaged them and was like, "Hey, I need to
borrow like, "Bro, I have like this bill coming up." I'm I've
probably got some friends from college I can borrow like borrow
like
a grand, three grand, five grand from that would just like they'd
just be like, "Yeah, you can get it back to me." Yeah. Okay.
assuming they didn't think I was like a like a drug addict or
something. But like I I got friends who would like totally be
there for me if I needed something, if I was like in a really
bad spot. They they are true friends. You just don't you're not
in proximity to them. You don't keep up with them as much. But
the idea that people who don't check in on you all the time aren't
true friends is just silly to me.
>> It's insane. And the worst thing is the biggest mistake
I've ever made in my life was that I was too loyal. Guys, you
know,
you know if you watch my content for any amount of time. >> How
does he do it? How does he do it? How does he do it every time?
Dude, what is he doing? Sorry, I I looked at my phone for a second.
I have to go back. I have to go back. >> Biggest mistake
I've ever made in my life was that I was too loyal. >> There's
no way. I pointed out that he told this to Ardite, right? The
only times I've ever I read to people is when I was too charitable
to them and I let them me in the back repeatedly. >> Guys,
you know,
you know if you've watched my content for any amount of
>> By the way, I this is like I feel like if you actually
thought this, you actually thought it, you wouldn't say I was
too loyal, right? You'd say I was a [__] I was a
You never go, "Oh, it was like a positive attribute. Take it
too far." You go, "I was a I was a [__] I don't know
what I was doing. I was not seeing things correctly at all. Yeah,
I was a idiot." If you actually think this, if you're just trying
to make yourself look cool or sound cool, then you go, "Oh, the
biggest mistake of my my of my life is uh
I was too loyal. Also,
I just love kittens too much.
I volunteer too much. Also, I donate to the homeless. Also, these
are all the mistakes of my life, okay? Like, come on, man. >> I
have every single person's back who I hold dear, no matter what,
without even them having to ask me.
>> This is just Tee saying for everybody, if anyone I was
friends with orworked with was accused of rape, okay, I'd have
their back. I wouldn't even look at the evidence. I'd have their
back. Okay. Think a little is enough to put me off as a friend?
No. No. No. No. No. No. I'm a true friend. Okay. I'm there through
thick and thin. No matter what size of woman you've, okay? Thick
or thin, I'm there for you. I don't know how many videos of mine
you've had to watch to know this, but you know if you've watched
more than three videos that if one of my friends comes in heat,
I'm there. I'm there for them no matter what. No matter what.
And those same people will will not have my back. Well, some
of them will. Very rare. Very, very, very rare. Very rare. But
you you guys know the guys who do have my back. And uh by the
way to you content creators who have been speaking kindly about
me. Um I don't want to mention you specifically by name but just
know I saw the clips. I appreciate you guys so much and uh thank
you for >> Asmin Gold. Asmin Gold. Asmin Gold. Thanks Asmin
Gold. Thanks for the shout out Asmin Gold. Love you Zack for
>> at least having a you know having my back online. It's
very rare these days. It is very rare. I'm taking a lot of this
time off to really get my head straight and really just try to
remember
why am I doing this? What's the goal? What do I want to be? Where
do I want to go? What do I want to show you guys?
I'm trying to enjoy my life as a human. And I really think I
am. I'm actually playing video games and I'm having fun with
them. That's very rare, right? I'm playing Fallout 4. I'm having
a blast.
Hi. How did I know? How did I know he took the time off? Just
kidding. I actually watched this part. But uh How did I know
he took time off to play video games? How did I I I actually
pre-watched in this case. In this one case, pre-watched. I knew
that Fallout 4 is actually, by the way, underrated.
So many people think Fallout 4 sucks. No, no, no. Macho,
no. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. You guys are wrong. Fallout
4,
uh, what is it? Safe Harbor.
Cold Harbor. What is it? The Fallout 4, whatever the harbor DLC
is. It's a Far Harbor. Far Harbor is fantastic,
bro. Far Harbor is so good. Far Harbor is so good. Uh, it's not
just Far Harbor, though. Or maybe it is. Is Far Harbor the one
with the uh the Children of Adam. Oh, it is the Children of Adam
one, too. Dude, that Children of Adam hideout and that was so
good. That was so good.
We need that back for TechOne. Anyway,
that that quick uh Memory Road pause, watch the New Vegas trailers.
Maybe we'll do it a little bit later. I listen listen. Uh the
god7 I actually think in the kick app it's like very difficult
to sub individually but I do appreciate you subbing individually.
So I'm not sure how you do it to be honest with you guys. Yeah,
we do have to get back to techone. All right, there's all the
techone stuff. There's all the core stuff we got to catch up
on. Oh my god, there's so much. And then the Destiny lawsuit
stuff. And that's not even that's to say nothing of the Hutch
Hassan doxing saga.
Dude, there's so much. We got to go. Okay, we got to Are we going
to continue? I'm going to roll back 10 seconds. Let's continue
with with that game >> as a human. And I really think I
am. I'm actually playing. >> Oh, I will say now that we've
gone an hour on the stream, guys. If you like the content, go
ahead, give some subs. Sub individually.
Sub on Twitch, sub on kick. Okay, Twitch is live right now, guys.
Throw me your Twitch primer. You got a Twitch. You got a primer?
Any primers in the chat? You got anybody with some Twitch primers
that they can throw out? Let me throw this uh URL over here.
Uh, every dollar you donate adds more time to the stream, guys.
More time to the stream. Uh, if if you don't want to sub on any
of the platforms, okay, you can also TTS. Exclamation point.
Donate in the chat. We'll allow you to TTS. Okay. >> Exclamation
point. Donate. That's Streamlabs. That's Kickbot. You can donate
either of those two ways. Marba dude, thank you for the gifted
sub. Appreciate it, buddy. Appreciate it. We
what are we? $12.
We are about six and a half subs, seven subs away from another
two hours on the stream. And we're going to need every hour.
All right, we're need every single hour. Can't believe you missed
the Hassan raid yesterday. I did indeed. I did indeed.
All right, we're going to need every hour, guys. So, fill up
the fill up the bank. Okay, let's go.
I'm having fun with them. That's very rare, right? I'm playing
Fallout 4. I'm having a blast. I'm almost done with the Brotherhood
of Steel. And Preston Garvey says, "Another settlement. Needs
your help for like the millionth time." And uh I'm running around
with Dog Meat. I got the mod where I made him a golden retriever.
And uh you know, I like to imagine that that he's Mango. I'm
me. And uh we run around the towns and we save the settlements
and we build up structures. And >> yo, Macho, thank you
very much for the gifted sub. >> Having a lot of fun
attached by the hip with my
>> damn son. Literally, there are so many subs on so many
different people that we had to give a sub to Botrix. The bot
the bots's got a sub. Awesome.
>> Soapbox Society, thank you for the five gifted. Let's
go.
That's what nine subs. Let's just put Let's just do it. Let's
just say that is all the time we needed for the extra 2 hours
on the stream. That's 4 hours. 58 44. Boom. Boom. Bang. What's
up?
What's up? Thank you very much, guys, for all the donations.
Really appreciate it.
Techie playing Fallout 4, pretending his dogs in Fallout 4. Great
time. >> Structures and I'm having a lot of fun. I'm literally
attached by the hip with my girlfriend non-stop and all my kitties
and my dog. And uh I hit a lot of new PRs on gym. I'm sick. I'm
owning in the gym right now. I think I can get 315. And uh if
I can, I'll make sure to post about that on Twitter. That'd be
his bench. 315. That's a big bench. I guess he's like a he's
like a pretty like like tall broad guy. I'm guessing he can bench
pretty well. >> But man, I miss content creation.
I really do.
I had one of my friends call me, talk to me, and they cried begging
me to take a break cuz they knew how
because guys, I'll I'll just be dead ass, man. Like a lot of
the people who have to deal with dead ass now a a lot of them
are deeply traumatized
for forever. A lot of them also kill
I don't want to end up like that. I don't I want to be okay.
>> A lot of I don't think a lot of content creators kill
themselves. Tactone. There's like I feel like we've got a handful.
And
I don't know why you'd This is This is maybe a little more disturbing
if you guys remember his previous video. his previous video where
he talked about how he's a massive fan of Reckful and then said
that he like didn't really know. What did he say? He was like
I do I have to go find his Reckful comments now? Hold on. Let
me go find them. If you guys remember his his previous like outside
video he did sitting in that wicker chair. How far back we got
to go for that one? Where's that one at? You guys know what I'm
talking about, right?
Where would it be? Where would it be? Where would it be? It's
got to be I think we've got to see it in the thumbnail, right?
That he's out in the wicker chair. Which one was it? Just stop.
No.
Can anyone find that video for me? I need that video now. This
guy just gives Arcadam vibes. I'm tough. Oh, is this Arcade?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I know. We love the Arcade bit. We did it for
his last thing. There it is. Streamers disgust me. Yes.
Thank you. Streamers disgust me. Oh, we got a time stamp here.
Talks about like his favorite >> Reckful Etekica
preach
because I don't believe you've truly died until people forget
about you.
And to those people, they meant so much to me. I uh don't really
want to let their memory die. A lot. >> Those people meant
so much to him. >> The people who I looked up to the most
in this world
have committed >> I'll be I'll be honest. Maybe he is right
that his friends reach out to him after this and like and like
we're like, "Hey, man. Are you good?
Techone, you are you good, buddy? What the fuck?" I'm going to
tell you guys, okay, I'm going just be real. A lot of the people
I looked up most to in this world have themselves. Uh, what?
Yeah, he's he's a little crazy. All right. >> Want to be
here and uh I I'll just listen, you know.
But I feel good. I do. Well, as good as I can feel like, okay,
you know,
let maybe I put this into words. I'm up. I know I'm up, but I'm
okay with that. And I know I'm working through it, so I know
I'm going to be okay. Does that make sense? Right. I know that
I am deeply up, but I've always beened up, so I'm okay with that.
And uh I'll get through this like I always get through this.
>> But uh things are a lot worse than you guys know behind
the scenes with some of the people that I'm dealing with. I just
I don't know why he'd be like, "I'm [__] up. I know
I'm up and then not like take some accountability for being like
a piece of to those people who are now he says lying about him."
I'm I'm guessing, man. I don't know. I can't really guess. But
like
I don't know how you like admit all of these things and you're
not like, "Yeah, they have some points. Listen, it's rough. >> I'll
get through this." like I always get through this, but uh th
things are a lot worse than you guys know behind the scenes with
some of the people that I'm dealing with. More than you guys
know, actually, more than you guys know. And uh you know, I'm
trying to take care of all that, hold it together. It does feel
very to be able to talk to you guys again. I'm actually really
looking forward to reading the comments cuz I I do miss this
a lot. I can't tell you how much this sucks for me, man. I like
I I don't I think you guys know this, but I'm I'm a very consistent
content creator. You know, I don't really go away too often.
This really is like my first real time taking any big amount
of time off.
I I don't know how long it'll be. Either a week, a month, 2 months,
3 months, 4 months, a year. There's no way it's going to be a
year. Jesus, that would be awful if it was a year. But I'll keep
you guys updated with all that [__] Yeah, I just
wanted to let you guys know. There probably other things I could
talk about in this video, but I'm just trying to make sure that
I'm all good. Taking some time off for the first time in a while.
Dealing with a lot of things behind the scenes that suck ass,
you know. >> You know, >> I'll talk more about it
later.
But just know that I really miss you guys. I do. And uh I hope
I get to get back to doing this pretty soon. And I would like
to let you guys know for anybody worried about me, don't be.
And I promise you guys, I am not going to Han aped him. Dude,
Hassan did like destroy this guy's life by pointing out his father's,
you know, the result of his father's military career. Han just
totally destroyed this guy. Obliterated him. Pull up his gay
tweets he made recently. Just give me a second. I'll be right
back. Dealing with a lot of things behind the scenes that suck
ass. You know, I'll talk more about it later.
But just know that I really miss you guys. I do. And uh I hope
I get to get back to doing this pretty soon. And I would like
to let you guys know for anybody worried about me, don't be.
And I promise you guys, I am not going to let any of you guys
down. And the story I get to tell you guys when I'm back, or
maybe a little bit after I'm back, is going to make a lot of
sense
when I can say the things that I want to say. And it's a very
important story I need to tell. Some of you guys watching this
can probably tell how deeply conflicted I am in my own mind right
now. And I can tell I'm at a very big
I'm at a very big pivot point or a very big like the moment I
am in my life right now is very important to who I'm going to
be for the rest of my life.
>> And I really have to take the time to make sure that
that person is someone who I'm proud of. >> I'm back >> and
someone who I'm going to enjoy being the rest of my life. So
I hope you guys understand why I'm not here right now. I look
forward to being back when I am back. I name other content creator
chats. I've been sent the clips and it's very cute and I I really
appreciate you guys and I do miss you guys quite a lot. I've
said that a lot. I do I don't I don't like taking this time off.
It sucks, but it's it's what's best for me. And so many people
have told me that I need to do this, so I'm going to do it. But
it feels like I'm in time out in my room right now. Jesus, these
birds. Anyways, this for the thousandth time, but uh miss you
guys.
Hope to get back to content creation pretty soon. probably not
going to be able to. I'll upload a couple videos every now and
then on this channel kind of in this format.
Bit more structured next time I talk. And uh yeah, hope you guys
are doing all right. And uh if there's one thing I can just ask
for any of you guys who are still here, imagine being forced
to give this guy this oath of BJ's.
Dude, realistically, Pikachu should get some restitution. Okay.
She She should That was That was the worst trade perhaps in the
in the history of trade deals. The worst trade in the history
of trades ever. Okay. Perhaps ever.
You get room and board and you just got to blow this guy. Yeah.
This is the worst deal ever. It's the worst. That's the worst
deal. That's terrible. >> Just uh don't forget about me.
Okay. Bye, guys.
See you later, Tone.